>>> WIN BLUES OR DRAW I'M GOING
TO ROCK WITH MY SOIL.
I UNDERSTAND.
I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND.
YOU GUYS ARE GIVING ME RIP ON VB
BETTING IN THE COMMENTS.
ALSO GIVING ME RIP IN MY DMs.
TALKING THAT TALK.
BUT DO NOT BE ALARMED.
DO NOT BE TOO HAPPY YOUR CELTICS
FANS.
BECAUSE THE WARRIORS BEEN HERE
BEFORE.
WE ACTUALLY BEEN HERE BEFORE.
YES I SAID WE.
BECAUSE I'M PART OF THE TEAM.
I GOT A RING.
WE HAVE BEEN HERE BEFORE.
2015.
I'LL GO BACK TO IT.
THE LeBRON JAMES JAMES-LED
CAVALIERS WAS GOING INTO GAME 4
UP 2-1 AGAINST THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS.
GUESS WHAT THAT GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS TEAM DID?
THEY WENT ON AND WON THREE IN A
ROW.
AND THAT WAS AGAINST LeBRON
JAMES.
I DO NOT THINK -- I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS CELTICS TEAM HAS
ANYBODY WE CAN MEASURE UP
AGAINST LeBRON JAMES GRANTED
TATUM IS REALLY GOOD.
TATUM IS REALLY, REALLY GOOD.
BUT HE IS NOT ON LeBRON JAMES'
LEVEL.
NOWHERE NEAR IT.
BUT ESPECIALLY LeBRON JAMES IN
HIS PRIME.
BUT LEAVES ME TO MY FIRST POINT.
BEFORE I GET TO THAT, THE SERIES
HAS BEEN VERY INTERESTING.
GAME 1, WARRIORS WERE UP 15
ENDED LOSING IT.
CELTICS SCORED 40 POINTS IN THE
FOURTH QUARTER.
AND THE WARRIORS END UP LOSING
ONE.
GAME 2 THEY BOUNCE BACK WITH A
SOLID WIN IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
THINGS WERE NECK AND NECK.
GAME 3, WEST COAST WENT UP.
BIG WARRIORS CLIMB BACK BUT THE
CELTICS HAD WHAT IT TOOK IN
ORDER TO TAKE GAME 3.
GAME 4 IS TONIGHT.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
GUYS ABOUT IS I DON'T EVEN KNOW.
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THIS WAS A
THING UNTIL I DIBEL,ED AND
DABBED ON TO FANDUEL.
I DIBBLED AND DABD.
AND I SAW THE GOENZ PLUS ONE AND
A HALF.
AND NOT ONLYLDEN STATE
WARRIORS PLUS ONE AND A HALF.
AND NOT ONLYBED.
AND I SAW THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS PLUS ONE AND A HALF.
AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT THAT WAS
PLUS MONEY.
I DON'T THINK THE CELTICS CAN
WIN THIS ONE IN SIX.
I DON'T.
IN FACT IF THE CELTICS DO WIN,
THEY WIN IN SEVEN.
IF THEY WIN IN SEVEN.
THAT MEANS THE SERIES BET OF
PLUS 1 1/2 FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS, THAT IS PLUS MONEY.
WILL CASH.
SO I'M JUST THROWING ANGLES AT
YOU GUYS.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE.
IF YOU THINK THE CELTICS CAN
TAKE IT IN SIX, WHICH I REALLY
DON'T.
DON'T BET IT.
BUT IF TO YOU THINK IF CELTICS
ARE GOING TO WIN AND IT IS GOING
TO BE A COMPETITIVE SERIES AND
GO BACK TO SAN FRANCISCO IN A
GAME 7?
HEY, BET THE SERIES SPREAD.
I GOT A SPECIAL GUEST FOR YOU
GUYS THOUGH.
I GOT A SPECIAL GUEST.
I CALL HIM S BOT.
YOU MIGHT CALL HIM SAM RICHMOND.
BUT ACTUALLY I HEARD THAT MY MAN
IS NOT READY.
SAM WHAT IS GOING ON?
BRO?
YOU'RE NOT READY WHEN WE'RE
READY FOR YOU?
THAT IS OKAY BECAUSE I CAN STILL
TALK GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS.
I CAN STILL TALK DRAYMOND GREEN.
ACTUALLY IN FACT MY MAN DRAYMOND
WAS VERY VERY VOCAL.
HE WAS VERY VOCAL AFTER THE
LOSS.
AND HE SAID THAT HE HAD TO PLAY
BETTER.
DRAYMOND THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS NEED YOU TO PLAY
BETTER.
DRAYMOND KNOWS.
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS, STEVE
KERR, THEY KNOW DRAYMOND HAS TO
PLAY BETTER.
I WAS TALKING TO MY BUDDIES
BEFORE I CAME ON THE SHOW AND I
WAS TALKING TO 'EM AND I WAS
JUST TELLING 'EM THE IMPORTANCE
OF IF DRAYMOND WAS A THREAT.
EVEN IF IT WAS 25% OF A THREAT.
IF I'M A DEFENDER AND YOU GOT
DRAYMOND COMING AT YOU AND HE'S
A THREAT TO SCORE.
SO THAT MAKES YOU THINK, AM I
GOING TO JUMP OUT AND DEFEND
DRAYMOND FROM SCORING?
AM I GOING TO PREVENT DRAYMOND
FROM SCORING?
AND IF I DO THAT U GUESS WHO'S
OPEN IN THE CORNER.
GUESS WHO'S OPEN IN THE WING?
STEPH CURRY, KLAY THOMPSON.
SO THAT IS THE IMPORTANCE OF
DRAYMOND GREEN IN THE WARRIORS
OFFENSE.
AND I THINK HA HE'S GONNA HAVE
TO.
HE'S GONNA HAVE.
I THINK HE'S GONNA MAKE AN
EFFORT TO SCORE TONIGHT.
AND HE'S GOING TO MAKE AN ERT TO
SCORE TONIGHT.
I ALSO THINK HE'S GOING TO MAKE
A EFFORT TO REBOUND BETTER.
A EFFORT TO THROW MORE ASSISTS.
THIS IS A BIG GAME FOR DRAYMOND.
A REALLY BIG GAME FOR DRAYMOND
AND I WONDER HOW HE'S GOING
BOUNCE BACK.
I INTO THESE COMMENTS THOUGH.
I'M INTO THESE COMMENTS
ACTUALLY.
NO LONGER CALLING IT THE
COMMENTS.
I'M INTO THE CHAT.
I HEARD MY MAN SAM IS BACK BUT
YOU ARE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT,
BROTHER.
YOU ARE GONNA HAVE TO WAIT
BECAUSE I'M INTO THIS CHAT.
AND I SEE BK 37 SAYS FADE TATUM.
HE'S PLAYED TOO WELL THE LAST
COUPLE GAMES.
IT IS TIME FOR ANOTHER 8 POINT
30% SHOOTING NIGHT.
ACTUALLY LET'S BRING IN SAM
BECAUSE I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THAT.
BEFORE YOU GIVE YOUR PICK, SAM,
THE CHAT IS TALKING THE CHAT IS
CHIRPING.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT JAYSON
TATUM IS NOT GOING OFF TONIGHT.
SAM, I WANT TO KNOW YOUR
THOUGHTS.
DO YOU THINK THIS IS A SWAP
WHERE JAYSON TATUM DO NOT GO OFF
TONIGHT?
>> IN THE CHAT I CAN'T SEE IT.
BECAUSE MY INTERNET SUCKS.
SO I HAD TO MOVE TO MY PHONE BUT
IF THE CHAT -- JAYSON TATUM,
THEN THEY ARE GOING TO HATE MY
FIRST PICK OF THE NIGHT.
WHICH I FEEL A GOOD SEGUE TO
GIVE MY PICK BUT I'LL WAIT FOR
YOU.
>> DO YOUR THING.
START OFF HOW YOU WANT TO START.
WOW.
OKAY.
SO YOU'RE FADING MY GUY IN THE
COMMENTS.
SAM IS FADING MY GUY IN THE
THERE IT IS.
YOU ARE GOING WITH TATUM OVER
26 1/2.
SAM, OFF THE TALK TO ME.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHAT IS YOUR REASONING BEHIND
THIS?
IS SAM FROZEN?
WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
GOING ON IN ATLANTA, SAM.
IS IT THE INTERNET OR IS IT YOU?
>> WE GOT A HEAT WAVE OVER HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND I'M SWEATING
LIKE I'M STEPH CURRY PLAYING IN
THE FOURTH QUARTER OF THE NBA
FINALS.
BUT WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH SAM.
I GOT SEND YOU MY AT&T ACCOUNT
AND GET THAT WIFI.
OH THERE HE IS.
SAM IS BACK.
NO MORE JOKES ABOUT YOUR WIFI.
YOU ARE BACK.
YOU ARE GOING WITH TATUM.
TATUM OVER TONIGHT.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHY WHAT IS THE REASON BEHIND
IT?
>> LOOK, HE HASN'T -- THIS JUST
FEELS LIKE A BIG TATUM NIGHT.
HE HASN'T EXACTLY GONE OFF IN
THE SERIES.
BUT THE THING I LIKE ABOUT IT IS
HE'S STILL GETTING HIS SHOTS UP.
HE'S UP AT LIKE 19, 20 SHOTS PER
GAME BUT HE'S SHOOTING 32%.
AND EVEN SHOOTING AROUND 32%
HE'S GETTING NEAR 26, 28 POINTS
THE LAST FEW GAMES.
I JUST FEEL LIKE HE'S TOO GOOD
OF A PLAYER NOT TO GET BACK ON
TRACK AND GET THE SHOOTING
PERCENTAGE BACK TO 40, 45%.
AND I ALSO HAVE A STAT THAT I
STOLE FROM OUR PRODUCER RYAN.
I HAD RYAN LOOK UP SOME STATS
FOR ME BEFORE THE SHOW.
AND HE TOLD ME, THAT JAYSON
TATUM IS AVERAGING 30 POINTS PER
GAME AFTER THE SERIES GOES TO
GAMES 4 THROUGH 7 IN THE LAST
FEW ROUNDS.
SO AS THE SERIES HAVE GONE
DEEPER, TATUM HAS GOTTEN MORE
COMFORTABLE AND GONE OFF.
AND I THINK THAT CONTINUES
TONIGHT.
THINK WE'RE GOING A TATUM
BOUNCEBACK.
>> SAM, OKAY.
I RESPECT THE TATUM TAKE.
I TOTALLY RESPECT THAT.
AND I DO THINK THAT ACTUALLY
PROBABLY CAN HIT.
I'VE BEEN ON RECORD SAYING THAT
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS DO NOT
REALLY DEFEND SUPERSTARS WELL.
WE'VE SEEN IN ROUND ONE.
IN ROUND TWO.
ROUND THREE AGAINST THE
MAVERICKS AND LUKA.
SO I CAN AGREE WITH YOUR POINT
THERE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT,
BRO.
YOU HAVE INTERNS OR OTHER PEOPLE
GOING TO LOOK UP STATS FOR YOU?
WHAT IS?
I NEED SOMEBODY TO GO AND LOOK
UP SOME STATS FOR ME.
WHAT IS THIS?
HEY, SAM COMES ON A COUPLE SHOWS
AND HE HAS INTERNS GOING TO GRAB
STATS FOR HIM NOW.
>> FIRST OF ALL.
RYAN IS NOT AN INTERN.
RYAN IS A LEGEND.
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE WE GIVE
RYAN HIS CREDIT.
>> RYAN IS LEGEND.
I'M SORRY RYAN.
YOU ARE NOT A INTERN.
>> -- BEHIND THE SCENES.
WITHOUT PEELING BACK THE CURTAIN
TOO MUCH IS OUR FRIENDS ON THE
APP TEAM.
A GOOD FRIEND OF MINE HIT ME UP
AND SAID YOU KNOW THAT PUSH
INNOVA
NOTIFICATION ALL OF OUR
FOLLOWERS GET BEFORE THE SHOW.
HE WAS LIKE I NEED A STAT BEFORE
THE SHOW.
I HAD TO GO GET A HAIRCUT
BECAUSE MY HAIR LOOKED AWFUL.
SO I AID RYAN CAN YOU HELP A
BROTHER OUT AND FIND ME A GOOD
STAT THAT I CAN STEND FOR THE
ALERT.
AND THEN I STOLE IT FOR THE SHOW
AS WELL.
LITTLE INSIDE BASEBALL THERE.
>> YEAH, I LOVE HOW YOU
WEDNESDAY IN BEHIND THE CURTEN
AND LET THE PEOPLE KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED.
AND RYAN WE KNOW YOU ARE NOT AN
INTERN.
I KNOW THAT.
AND SAM, I GUESS THIS IS A
PERFECT SPOT TO GO INTO YOUR
SECOND PICK.
AND HOPEFULLY I LIKE THIS ONE.
>> THIS IS A GOOD SEGUE.
I'M KEEPING IT GOING.
TATUM, FIRST BASKET, BABY.
PLUS 550.
LIKE I SAID.
I THINK --
>> WOW.
>> I THINK THIS IS A TATUM GAME.
I WENT BACK AND FORTH ON.
THIS BUT I DO THINK THIS IS A
TATUM GAME.
AND FUR GOING TO THROW A DARK
THROW.
PLUS 550 IS PRETTY NICE.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE FOCUSES ON
JAYLEN BROWN A LITTLE TOO MUCH.
I THINK HIS NUMBER WAS LIKE PLUS
380.
THIS TEAM STILL RUNS THROUGH
JAYSON TATUM.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING WANT TO
GET HIM GOING.
I THINK HE POPS A THREE BALL TO
START THE GAME.
I DON'T WANT WHAT THE FIRST
METHOD OF BASKET TATUM
THREE-BALL IS BUT IF THAT IS
PLUS,000 OR HIGHER, I LIKE THAT
AS WELL.
THIS IS OUR TATUM GAME TODAY.
>> HEY.
I DON'T KNOW IF IT IS YOU SAM
AND YOUR PICKS OR IF THIS IS
THIS CALIFORNIA HEAT WAVE THAT
IS MAKING ME SWEAT.
BECAUSE YOU ARE ALL OVER THE
CELTICSs OVER THERE BROTHER.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF I'M GELLING
WITH THIS.
BUT LET ME HOP IN THE CHAT AND
SEE WHAT THEY TALKING ABOUT.
I GOT RITTER SAYS A FIRST BASKET
PICK FROM SAM.
SAM, I GUESS PEOPLE -- RITTER IS
TRYING TO SAY YOU DON'T REALLY
CHOOSE FIRST BASKETS.
IS THAT LIKE A CREDIBLE SOURCE?
IS RATER A CREDIBLE SOURCE TO
SAY THAT.
>> THAT IS TRUE.
USUALLY JUST BET STRAIGHT BETS.
AND DON'T HAVE MUCH FUN WITH THE
PROPS.
BUT I'M KIND OF LOOKING TO -- I
CAN'T WANT TO STEAL YOUR PHRASE.
DIB AND DABBLE?
DIBBLE AND DAB?
>> YEAH.
>> YEAH I DECIDED I LIKE THE
IDEA JUST NOW.
I'M KIND OF SPRINKLING AROUND.
I KNEW YOU WEREN'T GOING TO LIKE
THE FIRST TWO BET SOYS SO I WANT
GET THEM OUT OF THE WAY RIGHT
AWAY AND THEN COME BACK WITH
ONCE YOU LIKE AND THEN COME BACK
WITH ANOTHER ONE YOU ARE GOING
TO HATE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY I ORGANIZED IT
THAT WAY BUT I THINK I'M GOING
TO GET YOU ON MY SIDE THE NEXT
FEW.
>> JU SANDWICHED IT UP.
THE NEGATIVE, THE BAD ON THE
ENDS AND INSIDE NICE AND WELL
DONE.
SOME GOOD JUICY BETS OR WHATEVER
WE WANT TO CALL IT.
GO AHEAD.
THAT LEADS IT.
BET NUMBER THREE, SAM.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHAT ARE YOU ROCKING WITH?
>> ALL RIGHT.
NEXT IS UNDER 214.
AND YOU LEAN UNDER WITH THESE
GREAT DEFENSES AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE HERE.
AND HERE IS MY TAKE.
I FEEL LIKE STYLISTICALLY
TONIGHT'S GAME IS GOING TO BE A
LOT MORE GAME 2 THAN IT WAS GAME
3 AND GAME 1 WHERE THE OVERS
HIT.
I THINK THIS IS A GAME WHERE
AGAIN WE SAW IN GAME 2 WHEN THE
WARRIORS WERE REALLY, REALLY
DESPERATE.
THEY CAME OUT AND DRAYMOND LED
THE WAY.
AND THE ENERGY AND THE DEFENSIVE
FOCUS WAS THERE FROM THE START.
AND WHILE I DO LIKE THE CELTICS
TONIGHT I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE THE GOOD DEFENSIVE EFFORT
ALL THE WAY.
AND I THINK THERE ARE OTHER
ACTOR
FACTORS HERE AT THE UNDER.
LEGS GET TIRED IN THE SERIES.
THIS IS THE ONLY GAME WITH ONE
DAY OF REST.
I THINK THAT FACTORS IN.
WE'RE GETTING INTO THE OWNED OF
THIS LONG PLAYOFF RUN FOR BOTH
TEAMS.
I THINK LEGS GET TIRED IN
GENERAL.
AND THEN, AND ACTUALLY -- MAYBE
I LIED THAT YOU WERE GOING TO
LIKE THIS.
I DON'T WANT TO BRING THIS UP IN
FRONT OF YOU.
BUT LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT STEPH
CURRY BEING A LITTLE HURT.
AND I THINK THAT PLAYS INTO THE
UNDER.
SO I'M ACTUALLY CURIOUS YOUR
TAKE ON THE STEPH STUFF.
OBVIOUSLY HE'S PLAYING TONIGHT.
DO YOU THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
FINE?
AS A WARRIORS FAN, ARE YOU
CONCERNED AT ALL?
OR YOU JUST TRUST STEPH?
>> SAM, I WAS ON MY PHONE
LOOKING UP INSTAGRAM, CHECKING
OUT MY FRIENDS OVER THERE AT
95.7 THE GAME.
I WAS ON THEIR INSTAGRAM FEED.
SHOUT OUT TO WHITLEY.
SHE'S THE SOCIAL MEDIA
COORDINATOR OVER THERE.
SHOUT OUT TO HER.
I WAS CHECKING OUT THE INSTAGRAM
AND I SAW STEPHEN CURRY WARMING
UP.
AND I WATCHED.
I WATCHED IT OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
AND THEY HAD MULTIPLE CLIPS,
MULTIPLE CLIP, DIFFERENT ANGLES.
AND I DIDN'T SEE A LIMP, SAM.
I DIDN'T SEE A GIMP.
I DIDN'T SEE A SLOW STEP IN HIS
STEP.
I DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING TO HAVE ME
ON ALARM THAT STEPH IS NOT GOING
STEPH TONIGHT.
SO I DID NOT SEE ANYTHING.
BUT ONE THING I DO WANT TO SAY,
AND I KNOW THE CELTICS FANS ARE
MIGHT GET ON ME ABOUT THIS ONE.
BUT THROUGHOUT THE PLAYOFFS.
THE CELTICS CONSISTENTLY WENT ON
SCORING DROUGHTS WE SAW IT GAME
TWO.
THAT GAME WENT UNDER.
IS HISTORY, THE TRENDS GOING TO
REPEAT ITSELF?
I'M TRYING TO BRING GOOD VIBES
TO YOUR UNDER BET.
BUT THE CELTICS SOMETIMES THEY
GO ON THOSE SCORING DROUGHTS.
AND WITH THAT HELP SAM IN HIS
UNDER BET TONIGHT?
I DON'T KNOW.
WE WILL SEE.
SAM YOU GAVE US THREE.
LET'S TALK FOUR.
WHAT IS THE FOURTH BET YOU ARE
ROCKING WITH?
>> YOU ARE GOING LIKE THIS ONE.
AND THIS GOES ALONG WITH THE
UNDER.
LIKE I SAID, I THINK START TO
FINISH YOU -- WE ARE GOING TO
GET A DESPERATE AND HUNGRY
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS TEAM
TONIGHT.
AND THERE IS NO BETTER EMB
EMBODIMENT OF THAT THAN DRAYMOND
GREEN.
I'M SO EXCITED TO WATCH DRAYMOND
GREEN PLAY BASKETBALL TONIGHT.
LIKE THIS IS GOING TO BE LIKE
GAME 2.
THIS IS GOING TO BE A DREAM.
I'LL SPOIL MY NEXT BET TOO.
I'M GOING DRAYMOND OVER .500.
THIS IS THE GAME FOR DRAYMOND.
THIS IS THE GAME WHERE HE SETS
HIS TONE.
AND YOU TALKED ABOUT LIKE WHAT
YOU SAW ON THE 95.7 INSTAGRAM.
I LIKE THAT.
.
I LOVE IN THIS NEW AGE OF
BETTING WE CAN GET INFO FROM
INSTAGRAM.
I GOT A LITTLE INFO FROM THE
DRAYMOND GREEN PODCAST WHICH I
LISTEN TO AND HE TALKED ABOUT
HOW GOING INTO GAME 3, HE WASN'T
HIMSELF BECAUSE HE LET EVERYONE
GET IN HIS HEAD AFTER, YOU KNOW,
WHAT HAPPENED IN GAME 2 WITH
LIKE MESSING WITH THE REFS AND
GETTING INTO IT, YOU KNOW, JUST
KIND OF BEING A DISRUPTER.
AND HE TALKED ABOUT.
HE WAS LIKE I LET TOO MANY
PEOPLE GET IN MY HEAD.
I WASN'T MYSELF IN GAME 3.
I NEED TO JUST BE THE GUY WHO
GOT KNOW WHERE I AM WHICH IS A
GREAT PLAYER.
I THINK HE'S GOING TALK A LITTLE
SMACK WITH THE CROWD TONIGHT.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE PUMPING
THEM UP TO BE LOUDER WHEN THEY
START THE DRAYMOND CHANTS.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE GETTING
IN JAYLEN BROWN'S FACE.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE GOING
AFTER EVERYONE.
AND THEN I ALSO THINK HE KNOWS
THAT HE NEEDS TO PLAY GREAT FOR
THIS WARRIORS TEAM TO WIN.
SO I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
MASSIVE ON THE GLASS.
I THINK THE KEY THAT EVERYONE
TALKED ABOUT AFTER GAME 3 WAS
THE CELTICS GETTING 15 OFFENSIVE
REBOUNDS.
I THINK HE KNOWS THEY GOT TO
CLEAN THAT UP.
HE'S THE GUY THAT IS GOING TO DO
THE DIRTY WORK.
CLEAN UP THE GLASS.
AND I THINK HE'S JUST GOING TO
IMPRINT HIS FORCE ON THE GAME
AND ALSO RACK OVER FIVE AND A
HALF SITS.
THIS IS THE DRAYMOND GAME.
>> I LOVE YOUR TAKE.
I LOVE YOUR TAKE SAM AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHY.
DRAYMOND PLAYS WELL.
THE WARRIORS WIN.
SO MY MAN SAM JUST BASICALLY
SAID DRAYMOND IS GOING TO COME
OUT.
HE'S GOING OVER REBOUND.
OVER ASSIST.
I'M GOING OVER ON THE POINTS.
DRAYMOND HAS A GOOD GAME, THAT
USUALLY TENDS TO MEAN THAT THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS WALKS OUT
OF WHATEVER ARENA THAT THEY ARE
IN WITH A W.
BUT I'LL LEAVE THAT THERE.
AND I WANT KNOW WHAT THE SIXTH
BET.
YOU KIND OF TEED ME UP, SAM.
YOU TOLD ME I WON'T LIKE IT.
SO I'M READY FOR IT RIGHT NOW.
>> SO MY INTERNET WHEN MY
INTERNET WENT OUT, I THINK YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE EXACT OPPOSITE
OF THIS BET.
BUT I AM GOING TO GIVE IT,
CELTICS MINUS ONE AND A HALF
GAMES.
I'M SORRY TO DO THAT, GREG.
I'M SORRY.
>> NO.
>> I --
>> TOWEL.
>> WE CAN PLAY BACK THIS TAPE
AFTER, YOU KNOW, STEPH WINS
FINALS MVP AND THE WARRIORS ARE
CELEBRATING COMING BACK AND
WINNING THE SERIES.
I THINK THE BOSTON CELTICS ARE
THE BETTER BASKETBALL TEAM.
I THINK THEY WIN TONIGHT.
I THINK THE HOME TEAM WILL WIN
EVERY GAME THE REST OF THE
SERIES.
I THINK CELTICS WILL WIN
TONIGHT.
I THINK YOU WILL GET A REALLY
BIG MOTIVATIONAL EDGE FOR THE
WARRIORS BACK AT HOME IN GAME 5.
I THINK THEY WILL WIN THAT GAME.
AND THEN I THINK THE BOSTON
CELTICS GOES THE DEAL.
AND IF THEY DO THAT, IF THE
SERIES PLAYS OUT LIKE, THAT I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER.
I GAVE OUT A 28-1 YOU KNOW ME.
I WOULD NEVER BRAG ABOUT A PICK.
I GAVE OUT A 28-1 THAT HAD
CELTICS WINNING GAME ONE,
WARRIORS WINNING GAME TWO.
CELTICS WINNING THREE AND FOUR.
-- THAT COULD STILL CASH.
I KNOW YOU PERSONALLY DON'T WANT
THAT TO CASH BUT FOR ME I WANT
THAT TO CASH.
I THINK THE TEAMS ARE VERY CLOSE
BUT I THINK BOSTON IS SLIGHTLY
BETTER.
SORRY DO THAT TO YOU.
>> THAT'S VERY DEBATABLE.
TO CALL THEM BETTER IS VERY VERY
DEBATABLE.
ALSO, BROTHER, I DON'T KNOW,
SAM.
YOU -- YOU MADE A POINT -- OKAY,
YOU MADE A POINT THAT MAKES
SENSE.
BUT JUST LET'S TAKE TONIGHT'S
GAME OUT OF IT.
LET'S TAKE TONIGHT'S GAME OUT OF
IT.
BECAUSE I THINK THE WARRIORS ARE
GOING TO BOUNCE BACK.
AND THEN YOU SAID EACH TEAM THAT
IS HOME IS GOING TO WIN THE
GAMES THAT THEY ARE PLAYING AT
HOME.
SO WARRIORS WIN TONIGHT.
LET'S TAKE TONIGHT OUT OF THAT.
WARRIORS WIN GAME FIVE.
BOSTON WINS GAME SIX.
DUBS TAKE IT IN SEVEN.
THAT'S HOW I SEE IT.
IT IS JUST HARD.
I DON'T KNOW, BRO.
YOU REALLY THINK THEY CAN WIN
IT?
SIX?
WHAT ARE YOU THINKING SIX OR
FIVE?
BOSTON WINNING IN SIX OR FIVE?
>> I THINK SIX.
AND I WILL SAY.
THIS I DO THINK IF THE
WARRIORS -- LIKE, THIS IS LIKE
YOUR VERY CLICHE LIKE SPORTS
RADIO TAKE EVERYONE SAYS.
BUT I THINK WHOEVER WINS TONIGHT
IS GOING WIN THE SERIES.
I THINK IF THE WARRIORS WINS
TONIGHT WHICH I THINK IS VERY
POSSIBLE.
I THINK THESE TEAMS ARE VERY
CLOSE.
I THINK THE CELTICS ARE LIGHTLY
BETTER.
AND I THINK WHEN THEY TOOK HOME
COURT ADVANTAGE AWAY IN GAME
ONE.
I THINK THAT WAS HUGE.
BUT I WOULDN'T BE STUNNED IF THE
WARRIORS WIN TONIGHT.
IF THEY DID, I THINK IT IS GOING
SEVEN.
AND I THINK THE WARRIORS WOULD
WIN IN SEVEN LIKE WE TALKED
ABOUT LAST WEEK.
IF IT GOES SEVEN GAMES I'M GOING
TO TRUST THE HOME TEAM WHICH
WINS GAME SEVENS ABOUT 80% OF
THE TIME AND THE VETERAN
EXPERIENCE OF THE WARRIORS.
AND ALSO, AGAIN, NOT A BIG LOOK
AT ME BRAG ABOUT MY BET GUY.
BUT I ALSO BET WARRIORS TO WIN
4-3.
SO IF THAT HAPPENS -- I'M JUST
FEELING GREAT, MAN.
I THINK IT IS EITHER CELTICS IN
SIX OR WARRIORS IN SEVEN.
I'M HITTING ONE OF THOSE SERIES
BETS I THINK.
AND YEAH, THIS IS GREAT.
THIS IS GREAT FOR ME.
I'M ON TOP OF THE WORLD.
>> YOU JUST CAN'T LOSE, HUH?
YOU JUST CAN'T LOSE.
YOU'RE JUST WINNING NO MATTER
WHAT.
I LIKE THAT MENTALITY.
YOU KNOW THAT WINNERS ONLY
ME
MENTALITY?
SO I'M GELLING WITH YOU.
RIGHT THERE WITH YOU WITH THE
MENTALITY I JUST DON'T KNOW
ABOUT SOME OF YOUR PICKS.
JUST SOME OF THEM IS JUST A
LITTLE IN LEFT FIELD.
BUT, YOU KNOW.
BUT YOUR HEART IS THERE AND
THAT'S ALL THAT MATTERS.
BK 37 SAYS EXPERIENCE WILL WIN,
SAM.
YOU TALKED ABOUT THIS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS FOR A
LITTLE BIT.
EXPERIENCE.
WE'RE ABOUT TO GET INTO -- LET'S
MAKE OUR OWN PHRASE, THE DOG
DAYS OF THE SERIES THAT.
MEANS THE CRITICAL GAMES.
THE GAMES THAT THE EXPERIENCE
TALL MATTERS.
DO YOU THINK THIS CELTICS TEAM
CAN FALTER OUT BECAUSE THE
WARRIORS HAVE MORE EXPERIENCE
THAN THEM?
IN THESE CRUCIAL, CRITICAL GAMES
LATER IN THE SERIES.
>> I THINK IT IS POSSIBLE.
BUT, MAN, I WAS REALLY IMPRESSED
WITH BOSTON WINNING THAT GAME 1
ON THE ROAD.
I WAS ABOUT TO SAY ORACLE.
AT CHASE CENTER.
AND I DON'T -- THEY HAVE JUST
BEEN SO BATTLE TESTED THIS
PLAYOFFS.
THEY HAVE HAD THREE ELIMINATION
GAMES.
THEY HAD GIANNIS, TWO AGAINST
GIANNIS.
ONE AGAINST THE HEAT ON THE
ROAD.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE EXPERIENCE
BUT THIS TEAM IS SUPER BALTTLE
TESTED.
THE ONLY PLACE I THINK THAT
EXPERIENCE WILL REALLY BE A BIG
DIFFERENCE I THINK IF IT GETS TO
A GAME 7.
I JUST THINK THAT IS GOING TO BE
A DIFFERENT ANIMAL BACK IN CHASE
CENTER.
WITH THE WARRIORS HAVING HOME
COURT AND LIKE I SAID, I
DON'T -- I -- I DON'T MEAN TO
KEEP REPEATING THAT STAT BUT
GAME 7 THE HOME TEAM WINS 80% OF
THE TIME AND FACTOR IN THAT
STEPH HAS BEEN THERE AND
DRAYMOND HAS BEEN THERE AND
KLAY'S BEEN THERE.
THAT IS WHY I THINK YOU ARE
GOING TO GET A VERY -- THAT'S
WHY I THINK THE WARRIORS ARE
GOING PLAY REALLY DESPERATE
TONIGHT.
BUT I ALSO THINK YOU ARE GOING
TO GET A REALLY DESPERATE
CELTICS TEAM TONIGHT AS WELL
BECAUSE I THINK THEY KNOW
PROBABLY IF THEY DROP ONE OF
THESE HOME GAMES THEY ARE GOING
TO BE IN BIG TROUBLE.
TO ME THEY HAVE TO WIN THIS
SERIES IN SIX.
BECAUSE I THINK IF THEY DROP ONE
THEY ARE GOING TO BE IN BIG
TROUBLE.
>> BIG TROUBLE.
AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
S DOT, WE GOT YO SIX, BUT MAN,
IT'S MY TIME, BRO.
IT IS MY TIME.
LETS ME HOP IN HERE.
YOU KNOW ME, BRO.
I'M ONLY LOOKING FOR ANGLES.
I AND GOT A DUO THE AUDIENCE.
I'M ABOUT TO POSE TWO BETS.
SAM, I ALSO WILL LOVE YOUR TAKE
ON THIS.
WE'RE GOING START IT OFF WITH
KLAY THOMPSON.
KLAY THOMPSON IS A VERY VERY
STREAKY PLAYER.
IF YOU FOLLOW THE WARRIORS.
IF YOU FOLLOW HIS CAREER.
KLAY GOES DOWN.
HE GOES HIGH.
HE GOES DOWN.
WHEN HE'S LOW.
HE'S LOW.
BUT WHEN HE'S HIGH, HE'S ON
FIRE.
SAM, LAST GAME MY MAN KLAY KIND
OF BROKE OUT OF HIS LITTLE
SLUMP.
HE SCORED 25 POINTS LAST GAME.
AND I THINK HE CAN DO THAT
TONIGHT.
KLAY USUALLY SEES THE BALL GOES
THROUGH THE NET.
THAT TENDS TO MEAN THAT USUALLY
MEANS, HE'S GONNA CONTINUE THAT
HOT STREAK.
HE'S GOING CONTINUE THAT FIRE.
HE'S GOING CONTINUE THAT TREND.
AND WE SEEN IT.
WE SEEN IT TIME AFTER TIME AFTER
TIME.
LET'S LOOK AT LAST SERIES, SAM.
PULL IT UP.
LET'S LOOK AT LAST SERIES.
MY MAN KLAY THOMPSON.
32 POINTS IN THE CLINCHER.
BEFORE THAT HE PUT UP 12.
BEFORE THAT 19.
302 IN THE GRIZZLIES.
MY MAN KLAY THOMPSON, HIS
NUMBERS ARE RELATIVELY -- THEY
ARE THERE.
THEY ARE AROUND THERE.
ANYWAYS, I'M GOING TO TO MY
POINT BECAUSE I WANT TO MOVE ON
TO MY NEXT BET.
25 POINTS AND THE GOERNS
WARRIORS TO WIN.
I CAN SEE THAT HAPPENING
TONIGHT.
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS IF
THEY WIN THIS GAME THEY CAN WIN
THE SERIES.
THIS IS HOW THEY CAN GO AND GET
HOME FIELD ADVANTAGE BACK.
WIN TONIGHT AND YOU GOT HOME
FIELD ADVANTAGE FOR THE NEXT
THREE.
I CAN SEE MY MAN KLAY THOMPSON
GOING THROUGHOUT AND PUTTING ON
A PERFORMANCE.
HE HAD 25 LAST TIME.
CONTINUING THE TREND OF ONCE
HE'S HOT, KLAY STAYS HOT.
GET 25 POINTS, GO GET THE WIN.
THAT'S PLUS 650.
I LOVE THOSE ODDS.
LET'S MOVE OVER.
CLON.
KEVON LOONEY.
I WOULD SAY HE'S BEEN A REAL
IMPORTANT FACTOR FOR GOLDEN
STATE WARRIORS THIS POSTSEASON.
KIND OF LIKE THE TEAM MVP.
THE WAY HE'S BEEN REBOUNDING THE
BALL, HAS BEEN REMARKABLE.
THE WAY HE'S BEEN REBOUNDING HAS
BEEN REMARKABLE.
BUT SAM, I'M LOOKING FOR ANGLES
AND I'M LOOKING FOR TRENDS.
LAST TIME THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS WON, AGAINST THESE
BOSTON CELTICS, MY MAN KEVON
LOONEY SCORED 12 POINTS AND 21
MINUTES.
STEVE KERR, I DON'T KNOW WHY, HE
DEDUCTED KEVON LOONEY MINUTES IN
GAME 3.
HE ONLY HAD 17 MINUTES.
SCORE 6 POINTS.
I THINK THAT HE'S GOING TO GET A
BUMP IN MINUTES TODAY.
WITH HIM GETTING A BUFFERIN IN
MINUTE, I THINK THAT HIS POINT
TOTALMP IN
TOTAL GOES UP.
I NEED HIM TO GET 10 POINTS.
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS WIN.
THAT'S SITTING AT PLUS 650.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC.
KLAY THOMPSON, 25 POINTS AND THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS TO WIN,
PLUS 650.
MY MAN KLAY SEEN IT LAST GAME.
HE SEEN THE BALL GO IN LAST
GAME.
SO I THINK HE'S GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE THE BALL GO IN
THIS GAME.
AND THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS WE
KNOW THEY NEED TO WIN THIS GAME
IN ORDER TO STAY IN THE SERIES.
KEVON LOONEY, WHEN HE PLAYS
GOOD, THE WARRIORS PLAY GOOD.
10 POINTS.
AND THE LAST TIME THEY KWON IN
GAME 2, HE SCORED 12.
I CAN SEE MY GUY OING OUT THERE
AND GETTING 10 AND THE WARRIORS
WIN.
SITTING AT PLUS 8 O 20.
I THIS WAS PLUS 850 BUT I
GUESSET WENT DOWN TO PLUS 820.
THE ODDS MAKERS KNOW WHAT'S UP.
WHICH UNWITHIN OF THESE IS THE
BETTER BET.
>> SO I LIKE WHAT YOU SAY ABOUT
KEVON LOONEY GETTING MORE
MINUTES TONIGHT.
I THINK EXACTLY THAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
I THINK KERR GOT SHOOK BASED ON
THE CELTICS DRAINING THREES SO
HE WENT IN A LITTLE SMALL.
BUT TO YOUR POINT THEY GOT
CRUSHED ON THE GLASS AS A RESULT
AND THAT ENDED UP BEING THE
DIFFERENCE.
KIND OF BACK FIRED.
I THINK IF HE'S LOOKING FOR AN
ADJUSTMENT.
I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
LOONEY BACK AND HIS NORMAL
MINUTES.
I LIKE IT.
MY CONCERN IS THAT I THINK HE'S
GOING TO GET A LOT OF REBOUNDS.
I'M JUST NOT SURE HE'S GOING TO
GET A LOT OF POINTS.
I SAID TO THIS YOU TO OTHER DAY.
HIS OFFENSIVE REBOUNDS SEEM TO
BE MORE IMPACTFUL THAN ELSE IN
THE LEAGUE BECAUSE HE ALWAYS
FINDS SOMEONE FOR THREE.
HE JUST HAS VERY GOOD VISION AND
I THINK HE'S GOING TO GET LOT OF
REBOUNDS.
I JUST THINK IT IS GOING TO TURN
A MORE INTO ASSISTS THAN POINTS.
I LIKE THE KLAY ANGLE BECAUSE TO
YOUR POINT, YEAH, HE'S VERY
STREAKY.
LIKE HE COULD HAVE NINE POINTS,
TONIGHT.
HE COULD ALSO HAVE 35.
I THINK THEY MIGHT RELY ON KLAY
A LITTLE MORE TONIGHT AGAIN
BECAUSE OF THE STEPH IS A LITTLE
BANGED UP ANGLE.
I THINK DRAYMOND IS GOING TO BE
OUT THERE LOOKING FOR KLAY TO
KIND OF TAKE SOME OF THAT
PRESSURE OFF STEPH.
I THINK STEPH IS PROBABLY GOING
TO BE LOOKING AT KLAY TO TAKE
SOME OF THE PRESSURE OFF HIM.
SO I THINK THAT IS THE RECIPE.
I THINK IF THEY ARE GOING WIN
YOU ARE GOING TO NEED A BIG PLAY
GAME.
SO YOU ARE BASICALLY GOING TO
GET WARRIORS MONEYLINE.
NOT APPLES TO APPLES.
BUT AT PLUS .650 FOR NORMAL
RECIPE FOR THEM TO WIN THE GAME
I THINK IS A REALLY GOOD PRICE.
>> COME ON NOW SAM.
TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
HEY I'M JUST THROWING ANGLES AT
YOU GUYS.
IT IS UP FOR YOU TO GRAB IT AND
GO WIT.
BUT I GIST WANT TO THROE AN
ANGLE SO YOU CAN THINK ABOUT IT,
PONDER AND THEN MAKEJUST WANT T
PONDER AND THEN MAKE YOUR
DECISION.
KLAY THOMPSON 25 POINTS AND THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS TO WIN.
I LIKE THAT.
KEVON LOONEY, YOU MADE REALLY
GOOD POINTS SAM.
I THINK KEVON LOONEY CAN SCORE
AND I'VE BEEN SEEING IT
THROUGHOUT THE PLAYOFFS.
STEPH CURRY, DRAYMOND GREEN
USUALLY DRIVING TO THE HOLE.
THE DEFENDER GRAVITATES TOWARDS
STEPH.
SOMETIMES DRAYMOND.
WHOEVER IT IS DRIVING, JORDAN
POOLE.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW MY MAN
LOONEY RIGHT THERE FOR THE EASY
LAYUP.
THE EASY DUNK.
I CAN JUST SEE A COUPLE OF MORE
OF THOSE OPPORTUNITIES HAPPENING
FOR LOONEY TODAY.
IF HIS MINUTES ARE BUMPED UP
FROM LAST GAME.
ALSO, YOU ALSO TOUCHED ON THE
OFFENSIVE REBOUND, SAM.
YOU GET AN OFFENSIVE REBOUND YOU
ARE RIGHT THERE.
PUT THAT THING BACK UP.
I LIKE BOTH BETS.
LET ME KNOW WHICH ONES YOU GUYS
ARE ROCKING WITH.
MIKE RITTER SAYS HE'S LIKING THE
LOONEY BET MORE.
I BET YOU DO BECAUSE IT IS
BETTER ODDS.
BUT I LIKE BOTH OF EM.
ONE THING, OOZE AIM DIBBLING AND
DABBLING.
I'M LITERALLY ON FANDUEL RIGHT
NOW.
DIBBLING AND DABBLING THROUGH.
AND SOMETHING THAT CAUGHT MY
EYE, SAM.
WOE WHOA.
THIS ONE'S CRAZY.
WAIT.
THE PRODUCER IS TELLING ME --
WAIT, WE HAVE A TWEET FOR IT.
LET'S PULL UP THE TWEET SO I CAN
EXPLAIN.
THIS ONE IS REAL LIFE CRAZY,
SAM.
READ THIS ONE AND READ THIS ONE
CAREFULLY.
THIRD QUARTER WARRIORS CONTINUE
TO BE INCREDIBLE.
GAME 1, YOU SEE THE RESULTS.
GAME 2, YES, YOU SEE THE
RESULTS.
GAME 3, NOTHING CHANGED.
YOU STILL SEE THE RESULTS.
LOOK AT THE BOTTOM.
YOU CAN SEE THE TOTAL POINTS IN
THIS SERIES, THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS COMPARED TO THOSE
BOSTON CELTICS IN THE THIRD
QUARTER.
SAM, AS I'M LOOKING ON FANDUEL,
I SEE WARRIORS THIRD QUARTER
WINNER SITTING AT PLUS 108.
IT IS PLUS MONEY, SAM.
MY MOM ALWAYS TOLD ME, IF IT
AIN'T BROKE, DON'T FIX IT.
I DON'T THINK THIS ONE NEEDS TO
BE FIXED, SAM.
TALK TO ME.
DO YOU THINK THE WARRIORS CAN GO
AND GRAB THE THIRD QUARTER YET
AGAIN IN THIS GAME?
>> I THINK -- I AGREE WITH YOU.
I THINK OFF THE TRUST AT THIS
POINT.
IF IT WAS JUST THESE THREE GAMES
WITH THE WARRIORS, WHERE THEY
WERE DOMINANT IN THE THIRD
QUARTER, MAYBE THAT IS ONE
THING.
BUT THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR THE ENTIRE STEPH ERA.
THIRD QUARTER WARRIORS IS A
THING.
THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY DOMINANT.
THE PLUS MONEY IS SUPER
INTERESTING.
BUT DO YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE NOT
TALKING ENOUGH ABOUT?
IS SECOND QUARTER CELTICS OR
FOURTH QUARTER CELTICS.
BECAUSE THOSE FOURTH QUARTER
NUMBERS FOR BOSTON ARE PRETTY
SIMILAR IN THE SERIES THAN THE
THIRD QUARTER WARRIORS STUFF.
BUT WE WON'T GET INTO THAT.
WE'LL JUST TALK THIRD QUARTER
WARRIORS PROPAGANDA.
BUT I THINK OFF THE LIKE IT.
THEY HAVE BEEN TOO GOOD IN THAT
OVER THE LAST THREE, FOUR YEARS.
>> SAM, HONESTLY BRO, I LIKE
MONEY.
I LOVE YOUR ANGLE.
TALK ABOUT THE CELTICS FOURTH
QUARTER.
TALK ABOUT IT BECAUSE MONEY IS
MONEY.
AND THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING IT
DONE IN THE FOURTH QUARTER.
WE'VE SEEN TIME IN TIME OUT.
WE'VE ALSO BEEN SEEING THE
WARRIORS GETTING IT DONE IN THAT
THIRD QUARTER AND IT IS PLUS
MONEY.
BUT SAM, BRO, MY TIME WITH YOU
HAS BEEN WELL.
I'VE ENJOYED THIS.
GOING BACK AND FORTH WITH YOU.
ABOUT CELTICS/WARRIORS.
WE GOT TO OFF LINE ON SOME
THINGS.
WE GOT TO GET YOUR HEAD STRAIGHT
ON SOME STUFF THAT WE DISCUSSED
TODAY.
BUT THAT IS OKAY.
HEY, TILL NEXT TIME, BROTHER.
TILL NEXT TIME.
MY NAME IS GREG IVORY.
THAT IS SAM RICHMOND.
WE ARE UP OUT OF HERE.
PEACE.
♪